mais d'abord donc notre journal de
campagne où il est question de barrage
républicain jérôme barbier
après une soirée deux premiers tours où
les porte-paroles d'ensemble ont semblé
chercher une formule elisabeth borgne a
fini par trancher aucune voix pour
l'extrême droite a dit la première
ministre tout en demandant de ne
soutenir que les candidats dits
républicains au cas par cas une entorse
au traditionnel front républicain face à
l'extrême droite et au niveau local les
situations divergent même quand le parti
demande de se retirer comme dans la 2e
circonscription du lot et garonne le
candidat en marche résiste finalement
dans un communiqué alexandre fraîchit
annonce maintenir malgré le risque de
victoire du rassemblement national
certains souhaitent que nous a dit
qu'ils ont nous ne cédons pas aux
appareils politiques chacun semble se
faire sa propre définition comme
l'ancien ministre des sports roxana
maracineanu qui appelle à un front
républicain
mais contre l'extrême gauche dans le
duel qui l'opposait à rachel kéké
candidate de la nuque qui l'a devancé au
premier tour dans le val de marne à
droite le front républicain avait déjà
du plomb dans l aile mais une nouvelle
ligne est désormais franchie le
président du sénat gérard larcher a dans
un communiqué appelé les électeurs à ne
donner aucune voix aux extrêmes pour lui
la nuque et le rassemblement national
représente le même danger pour notre
pays une position désormais reprise par
de nombreux élus les républiques moi je
ne voterai jamais pour les extrêmes et
je met dans le même panier extrême
gauche extrême droite donc moi c'est
très clair pour moi le président de la
république n'a pas été plus explicite
lors de sa prise de parole avant son
départ pour la roumanie entretenant le
flou installé dans cet entre-deux-tours
dimanche aucune voix ne doit manquer à
la république à défaut d'une consigne
claire des états majors des partis comme
toujours ce sera aux électeurs de
trancher et de mettre en pratique ou non
un front républicain
trois grands thèmes donc je voulais ni
dans notre débat on commence tout de
suite avec emilie appel ce qui bon soir
bienvenue vous êtes communiquant de
politique mathieu sous pierre bonsoir et
bienvenue essayiste je rappelle le titre
de votre livre
2022 la flambée populiste et publié chez
plon au co écrit avec damien fleurot
jean daniel lévy bonsoir bienvenue
directeur délégué d'harris interactive
et matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bonsoir mathieu émises appel
ce qui ce front républicain
d'émana convient d'entendre un extrait
de sa déclaration sur le tarmac d'orly
l'appel d'orly on pourrait dire c'est un
front républicain à géométrie variable
est ce que vous le définiriez comme ça
moi je me suis posé la question c'est
est un front républicain ou un front
macro nhien puisque finalement ça se
définit comme ça en tout cas de la façon
dont il l'a expliqué sur le tarmac
c'était en dehors de moi rien et
républicains et d'ailleurs c'était
étonnant puisque la mise en scène
voulait que derrière rêver un avion avec
marqué en gros la république française
puisqu'il s'envoler directement vers la
moldavie pour la guerre en ukraine on
voit que c'est en effet à géométrie
variable et
soit invoquée le front républicain une
fois pour la présidentielle une fois
pour les législatives mais c'est une
question de cohérence c'est à dire on
peut pas appeler la gauche a voté contre
marine le pen aux présidentielles et
puis à la présidentielle est invoqué à
nouveau le front républicain dans
l'autre sens c'est cette question de la
cohérence moi je pense que le sursaut
républicain comme il l'appelait ça peut
encore fonctionner y compris contre jean
luc mélenchon mais plutôt sur un vote
utile est là pour le coup la
personnalité de jean-luc mélenchon enfin
peut-être jean daniel le sait mieux mais
elle est assez clivante c'est le
paradoxe de jean luc mélenchon parce que
c'est grâce à lui que l'union se fait la
nuque qui était quand même assez
inattendu mais c'est peut-être à cause
de lui aussi que l'essai ne se
transforme pas en tout cas pour le rang
de premier ministre parce que il est
très clivant c'est un repoussoir pour
une partie de l'électorat de gauche on y
reviendra évidemment mais je reste sur
cette notion de de front républicain et
peut-être aussi mathieu soupière de
discours alors pas forcément des manuels
macron m'aider des chefs à plumes de la
macro ni on va dire que ça on va dire ça
comme ça si on compare ce qu'ils
disaient au soir du premier tour de la
présidentielle
et puis deux mois après au soir du
premier tour des législatives
les électeurs ici
ils ont le tournis quoi forcément oui ce
qui est étonnant c'est qu'on peut même
faire la comparaison de ce qui a été dit
en tout début de soirée dimanche ni en
fin de soirée dimanche donc c'est assez
étonnant que les éléments de langage et
pas été davantage calais sur le fond je
rejoins totalement ce que disait émis il
ya quand même une forme d'incohérence
total même alors on sait que le
maquereau nisme se distingue par sa
plasticité idéologique mais à ce point
il ya un vrai problème et encore une
fois sur la méthode sur la forme on est
étonné c'est quand même une des deux ou
trois questions principales qui allait
se poser au soir du premier tour donc on
est bluffé que la première ministre
elle-même en fait est autant patouiller
dans ses premières déclarations en se
contredisant elle-même à quelques heures
d'intervalle alors ensuite et
probablement que on a joué au feu on a
joué avec le feu en macro ni en passant
de la dénonciation du péril brun à la
présidentielle au péril rouge aux
législatives dès lors qu'il y avait un
péril brun est un péril rouge forcément
on doit se prémunir des deux mais à la
fin ça aboutit quand même à une forme
d'incohérence politique qui pose
nécessairement problème je j'ajoute un
tout petit élément j'entendais la
sénatrice des républicains qu'il
renvoyait dos à dos extrême gauche et
extrême droite encore une fois la nuque
c'est une coalition alors je n'ignore
pas que cette coalition coalition est à
ce stade dominé à travers le rapport de
forces issu de la présidentielle par la
partie la plus radicalisés de la gauche
mais c'est une coalition qui agrège
aussi europe ecologie les verts le parti
socialiste et donc je n'avais pas en
tête jusqu'à présent en fait que le
parti socialiste et qu'europe écologie
lire ceci dit hors du champ républicain
c'est d'ailleurs ce que disait olivier
faure ce matin dans l'une des matinales
radio jean dell et vie est-ce que ça un
quelconque effet ces consignes de vote
sur les électeurs quand on parle de
front républicain on a vu dans le
reportage de jérôme que localement déjà
ça pouvait se friter mais on peut déjà
prendre la dernière présidentielle
on a eu une hausse de l'abstention entre
le premier et au deuxième tour on a le
rassemblement national marine le pen
dans l'espèce qui est aux portes du
pouvoir et d'ailleurs on a vu que
l'avait dépassé largement les 40 % ce
qui n'était pas une surprise d'ailleurs
d'un point de vue d'opinion et tout le
monde savait qu'elle pouvait réaliser un
très bon score et même un son de
français pour penser qu'elle pouvait
gagner la présidentielle et pour autant
ils sont pas forcément déplacés pour
aller voter contre marine le pen le
deuxième aspect qui est assez marquant
c'est que vous avez quand même trois
millions de français qui sont allés
voter au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et qui ont pris un
bulletin blanc ou nul c'est à dire que
qui ont été jusqu'au plus loin possible
pour eux de l'acte civique mais qui pour
autant refusé de choisir entre marine le
pen et emmanuel macron un million de
françois xavier a très vite oublié
pendant sa conduite ou blessent qu'il
s'agit d'une exception la réponse est
non on peut revenir quasiment en fait
aux élections régionales de 2015 ou déjà
à l'époque on avait vu en fait que on
s'en souvient avec le ratio national été
la première formation déjà politique de
france en décembre 2015 28 pour son
premier tour des élections régionales et
qui n'avait pas empêché le front
national de progresser dans quasiment
toutes les régions au deuxième tour et
même l'élection présentielle précédente
nous avons eu lieu exactement le même
phénomène c'est à dire une progression
de l'abstention entre le 1er et au 2e
tour alors que hormis en 1969 qui a
toujours eu plus d'électeurs au deuxième
tour par rapport au premier tour est
déjà en 1900 en 2002 17 4 millions de
français qui avait procédé de la même
sorte c'est à dire pris un bulletin
blanc ou nul au deuxième tour avec
marine le pen et emmanuel macron qui
était qualifié pour le deuxième tour
alors ce front républicain en écoute
ensemble ce qu'en dit le président du
rassemblement national jordan bardella
c'était ce matin sur europe 1 le barrage
pro loi et les castors sont un peu
fatigués parce que on voit qu élection
après élection on engendre un des
millions et des millions de voix en plus
donc c'est vrai que le chemin est petit
c'est un long parcours initiatique c'est
peut-être plus dur que pour les autres
mouvements politiques donc moi je dis
aux français résiste et amplifier
confirmer votre vote et donnez nous un
groupe puissant regarder avec six
députés sur 577 on a réussi en cinq ans
imposer nos thèmes dans le débat public
arrive au second tour l'élection
présentielle dont je vous laisse
imaginer ce que ça peu mais dans cinq
ans avec 40 50 60 ou 100 députés à
rennes
il a beau jeu de dire ça mathieu genre
de bardella parce que on peut même se
demander si ce n'est pas la fin du front
républicain à laquelle on assiste était
déjà effritée on l'a bien compris manuel
maquereau en mettant sur le même plan la
nuque et le rassemblement national vient
pas tout simplement at il pas tout
simplement le faire disparaître ben
c'est le dernier stade louis ii la
banalisation une certaine façon du camp
vous crier au loup on vous crier au loup
deux fois trois fois quatre fois les
gens finissent pas pu avoir peur du loup
désirent passer le loup bien pourquoi
pas
c'est en fait ça ça pose surtout à mon
avis une vraie question sur ce qu'elle
ma chronique aujourd'hui on en a dit un
mot qui ne se définit plus
comme c'était le cas en 2010 est d'une
certaine façon de manière positive
si vous m'élisez voilà ce que je ferais
voilà comment je les bloquerai la france
voilà comment il sera mon programme mais
qui est un projet en contre on a vu
contre la droite au premier tour de la
présidentielle contre l'extrême droite
au second tour de la présidentielle
contre l'extrême ce qu'il appelle
l'extrême gauche aux législatives
et du coup quand vous vous positionnez
en contre et non plus en cours eh ben ça
donne campagne complètement atone
d'interroger les candidats la république
en marche la renaissance maintenant ils
n'arrivent plus à faire campagne parce
que au fond la seule mesure emblématique
c'est cette fameuse retraites sur
laquelle ils ont bien du mal à dire si
elle sera à 65 de 64 ans sur l'éducation
la santé on peut dire ce sont des thèmes
des grands chantiers prioritaires mais
so what qu'est ce qu'on fait le présent
d'un public a donné des pistes mais
c'est un papa très concret et donc du
coup quand on s'est demandé au bout de
cinq ans au fond c'est quoi le maquereau
nice pour delà d'être un pragmatisme
ben on n'a pas plus avancé sur sur la
question et cet appel au fonds
républicain et cette détermination
encontre fait que au bout d'un moment ça
finit par lasser et mon ami mais jean
daniel lévy que disent les projections
la en sièges que vous avez pu réaliser
toute dernière alors déjà je vais vous
dire la même chose que ce que je vous
dis jusqu'à présent à chaque fois soyons
prudents c'est bien on est on est les
premiers à dire ça
me laissera pas un petit peu moins
vendredi prochain parce qu'on aura eu le
temps de réinterroger les français
basque où on l'offre électorale réel
uniquement depuis hier 18h d'accord donc
en fait c'est on n'a pas pu complètement
retravaillée après ce qu'on a regardé
c'est un peu les logiques la logique
fait que ça n'est pas certain que la
majorité soit et la majorité absolue et
on à l'heure actuelle quand on prend non
seulement les résultats du premier tour
mais également ce que nous déclare
dimanche dernier les électeurs dans
leurs intentions de comportement dans le
cadre du deuxième tour une situation qui
est évalué entre 2 157 et 297 sièges
pour la majorité présidentielle on veut
rappeler que 297 sièges c'est pas très
loin de la majorité absolue de 180 190
voilà mais que c'est plus loin d'être
confortable surtout la grille de lecture
qu'on a au soir du premier tour des
élections législatives de 2022 ne
ressemble en rien à la grille de lecture
qu'on avait au soir du premier tour des
élections il est steve de 2017 ya cinq
ans on évaluer la possibilité pour la
majorité d'obtenir 400 voire 4 130
sièges au final ils ont obtenu à peu
près 350 sièges et donc en fait
aujourd'hui l'élan dont on parlait tout
à l'heure où cette absence d'élan se
manifeste même dans le cas des élections
initiative où il n'y a pas une situation
de dynamique politique ça s'inscrit
d'ailleurs dans une logique absolue
quand vous regardez au premier tour des
élections législatives de 2010 est la
majorité présidentielle avait recueilli
32 % des suffrages dimanche dernier
c'était 26% des suffrages à quelque
chose près en fonction d'un million
d'hommes à comptabiliser les différents
candidats et la nuque la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale sera
selon toute vraisemblance là aussi on
est présent là la première force
d'opposition premier groupe d'opposition
à l'assemblée je pense que jonathan du
prix s doit être juste la bonsoir
jonathan on va voir que les grandes
manoeuvres ont déjà commencé entre la
majorité présidentielle et la nuque
notamment pour les postes le poste le
plus prestigieux à l'assemblée nationale
la commission des finances thomas et au
vu des rapports de force politiques la
nuque deviendra vraisemblablement le
premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée avec 150 à 200 députés
suivant les projections de fait est bien
ensemble et l'union de la gauche vont
devoir se répartir les postes clés du
palais bourbon questeur vice-président
et pourquoi pas et bien la fameuse
stratégique présidence de la commission
des finances chargé notamment de
l'examen du budget et ce sera un poste
rêvé pour la nuque pour bloquer la macro
ni sur des arbitrages pourquoi pas
essentiel financier très important
évidemment pourquoi la nuque revendique
particulièrement cette commission ce
poste en vertu de quoi en fait depuis
2008 il ya une révision
constitutionnelle sous nicolas sarkozy
est dans la constitution maintenant eh
bien il ya une reconnaissance en fait à
l'opposition parlementaire de certains
droits spécifiques ça s'est traduit par
une modification du règlement de
l'assemblée nationale en 2009 et donc
depuis l'article 39 dispose ainsi vous
allez le voir que ne peut être élu à la
présidence de la commission des finances
qu'un député appartenant à un groupe
s'étant déclarés d'opposition si le
règlement de la haine
une l'assemblée nationale ne précise pas
que c'est le premier groupe d'opposition
et bien dans les faits il ya une
tradition coutumière à l'assemblée qui
fait que c'est toujours le premier
groupe de l'opposition qui récupère ce
siège prestigieux l'assemblée nationale
me disais tout à l'heure et bien c'est
un peu une manière de garantir une sorte
de bonne intelligence un bon
fonctionnement de la mandature à venir
comme donc logiquement la présidence de
cette commission des finances devrait
tomber dans l'escarcelle de la nuque
mais avec quelles composantes de cette
union des gauches alors là c'est le
moment tambouille c'est là que ça se
complique après les législatives les
députés de la commission des finances et
bien ils vont être amenés à élire leur
président présidente traditionnellement
la majorité dans ces cas là ne
participent pas au vote du présidente de
cette dite commission c'est une
tradition mais attention pas une
obligation et c'est là que tous les
coups tordus son possible pour bloquer
par exemple et les fille qui serait
jugée trop radicale et qui pourrait
prendre la tête de la commission est
bien la macro ni elle pourrait pourquoi
pas nouer des accords de circonstance on
va dire avec dlr pourquoi pas des
socialistes dissidents afin d'élire un
parlementaire qui serait certes de
gauche certes d'opposition mais qui sait
y irait beaucoup plus dans leur sens et
ce qui en un profil on va dire plus
constructif pour eux s'ils font ça en
revanche c'est ce serait un précédent 1
thomas et ça pourrait surtout être un
calcul politique à ces risques et
écouter ce qu'on disait benjamin morel
position n'a pas pour vous embêter que
la présidence de la commission des
finances elle va avoir parce que la
proportionnelle un vice président un
vice-président regarder la manière dont
marc lefur anime les débats sur la fin
du cumul des mandats en 2013 vous allez
comprendre ce que c'est d'avoir un
vice-président de l'opposition contre
vous quand vous animer un débat qui est
tendu c'est à dire que tout d'un coup ça
peut créer vraiment des manoeuvres qui
vont être des manoeuvres extrêmement
compliqué ensuite à gérer vous avez par
ailleurs les droits de tirage et cetera
les temps de parole tout ça peut être
extrêmement compliqué à gérer donc c'est
plutôt intérêt pour le bien de votre
propre majorité à avoir quand même un
rapport aux relativement apaisée avec
votre principale opposition à jonathan
vous nous rappeler pourquoi ce poste et
si recherchée parce qu'ils octroient
quand même de grands pouvoirs à au
groupe qu'il exerce un fixer l'ordre du
jour de la commission auditionné des
ministres créer pourquoi pas des
commission denquête qui ont aussi l des
pouvoirs étendus d'investigation qui
peuvent faire sauter des verrous en
matière de documents administratifs à se
procurer en des termes finalement assez
simple un la commission des finances en
fait peut savoir en temps réel l'état
des finances publiques et c'est
d'ailleurs pas pour rien qu'on avait
souvenez-vous pendant la présidentielle
qu'on avait présenté eric woerth un
comme une sacrée prise de guerre des
manuels macron à vous le voyez à l'écran
pendant la présidentielle le député l
air de l'oise qui occupait ce fameux
poste de président de la commission des
finances depuis des années eh bien il
avait abandonné le camp pécresse au
profit du chef de l'état sortant et ce
qui neutralise est de faire un opposant
de poids merci jonathan c'était
passionnant mathieu soupire ce sera on
peut déjà écrire une des premières
polémiques la nouvelle assemblée surtout
on comprend effectivement que
l'organisation politique des cinq
prochaines années va se structurer
autour de l'opposition entre ensemble le
camp macro nist et la nuque
rappelons puisque jean daniel parlait
tout allant de l'abstention qu'on va se
retrouver du coup avec deux forces
politiques qui vont dominer de façon
très nette de façon écrasante le
parlement l'assemblée nationale an
représentant à elle toute seule à elles
deux cumulé en fait 25% de l'électorat
25% de l'électorat compte tenu en fait
de l'abstention et je dirais que quelle
que soit la majorité qui l'emportent
c'est dire que si c'est elisabeth bande
qui demeure à matignon où jean luc
mélenchon qui se fait donc élire au
poste de premier ministre on va avoir un
projet de société avec par exemple la
retraite à 60 ans ou par exemple la
retraite à 65 ans et dont quinze jours
c'est ça qui nous pend au nez c'est donc
pas exactement la même perspective et
ont tout état de cause que ce soit la
retraite à 60 ans ou la retraite à 65
ans ce sera porté par une majorité
politique qui ne représentera que quoi
12 13% des français au plan électoral
donc ça dit quand même que l'assise l'a6
dont disposera le camp majoritaire sera
en réalité très faible on ne sait pas
très bien où on va quand même émises à
pastis et on l'a bien compris c'est une
tradition fans on s'est inscrit dans les
dents dans le règlement cela semblait
mais moi j'avais parlé de tradition
récente d'une certaine façon on peut
dire ça si emmanuel mal qu'ont ils
dérangent d'une façon ou d'une autre ou
alors va effectivement chercher un
député d'une socialiste par exemple est
ce qui marque son sectarisme comment ce
sera analysée d'impôts en tout cas il
serait cohérent parce que encore sur le
tarmac il a dit que s'il avait pas la
majorité absolue ce serait le désordre
alors on peut entendre des ordres on
peut entendre retour de la discussion
parlementaire puisque finalement c'est
ce que réclament une majorité de
français qui souhaitaient la
cohabitation donc ça serait assez
cohérents avec ce qu'il a dit ça serait
probablement mal pris ça serait très
tactique mais comment le disais à
l'instant c'est vrai qu'on a un emmanuel
macron beaucoup plus tacticien que
stratège moi je reviens sur ce clivage
j'ai l'impression qu'à l'assemblée alors
c'est un drôle de clivage de retour
droite gauche j'ai l'impression qu'ils
ont refait surface alors une gauche un
peu radicaliser parce qu'en effet emmené
par la france soumise mais quand même
cette gauche et je trouve que c'est
assez réussi de la part de jean luc
mélenchon sur le dossier des retraites
justement d'avoir pu amener cette
projection de projet de société contre
projet de société c'est à dire la
retraite à 60 ans le smic à 1500 euros
des choses très précises et en face
comme le disait mathieu tout à l'heure
aucun programme c'est à dire aucun
contre programme dont quelque part il a
occupé l'espace gauche est en phase bas
par défaut emmanuel macron et occupent
l'espace aux droits même droite même
s'il n'a même pas délimité son programme
puisqu'on sait pas exactement ce qu'il
va faire et que pour l'instant j'ai
appelé ça la boule à facettes depuis la
présidentielle c'est à dire que à chaque
fois qu'il ya un résultat intermédiaire
ils essaient de distribuer aux plus
large il l'a fait durant
l'entre-deux-tours à la présidentielle
un peu d'écologie un peu de changement
d'âge pour la pour l'âge de la retraite
et il est en train de le faire pour les
législatifs mais je ne suis pas sûr que
ça marche globalement très bien mme
mathieu cet enjeu la présidence de la
commission des finances ce sera aussi on
imagine que c'est un défi à sa tête ce
sera aussi un bon test républicain
puisqu'on revient à notre première
thématique pour pour et les filles à bas
ce sera oui un bon test républicain je
peux vous dire qu'il ya quelque chose
qui inquiète beaucoup dans le maquereau
n'y ait pas que à propos de cette
présidence de la commission des finances
et que le président de la commission des
finances a accès à tous les dossiers
fiscaux sur pièce
alors il se soumit une forme de
confidentialité bien entendu mais c'est
quelque chose qui inquiète beaucoup et
oui ça sera un test parce que si on veut
qu'il ait des débats intéressants sur le
budget et conçoit pas dans l'opposition
systématique parce que on l'a déjà dit
ici mais on rails souvent la majorité
playmobil c'est le jeu institutionnel
donc un petit peu et particulièrement
playmobil souleymane macro mais il ya
une opposition playmobil auscitains qui
votent comme un seul homme la france a
soumises j'ai pas vu beaucoup de députés
et les fit voter contre l'avis de jean
luc mélenchon ou un avis différent donc
et si on veut se sortir de cette logique
binaire on pourrait espérer que on ait
des débats intéressants la commission
des finances je n'y crois pas tant que
ça parce que c'est comme c'est un levier
de pouvoir est en tout cas un poste où
on a une parole qui est plus forte que
les autres ils vont s'en servir
davantage dans la vie comme d'une
tribune que comme d'un la laboratoire de
compromis politique oui et puis alors si
on parle d'un emmanuel macron stratégie
peut aussi se servir de cette nomination
pour mettre un coin dans l'unité ou là
où la cohérence de la nuque on verra
bien les bibis intervenir sinon c'était
ce qui peut être intéressant n'aura pas
faire doublon l'élection avant qu'elle
ait lieu mais ce qui est pas impossible
c'est que si jamais en fait la majorité
présidentielle n'a pas la majorité
absolue
ce sera du fait de la poussée de la
gauche et tu puisses y voir un effet
paradoxal que la politique au final soit
plus de droite c'est ce qu'ils écoutent
et de la mi-mars
de faire une alliance montrait qu'il
aura besoin d'avoir des soutiens qu'elle
soutient indéniablement il les aura pas
du tout du côté de la nuque peu de
chance en fait qu'il les aide de la part
des personnes qui soit dit larouche donc
il devra faire alliance en fait avec des
personnes qu'ils ont à droite sur
l'échiquier politique là on a vu que
tous les élèves ne sont pas forcément
sur la même ligne politique hassan
d'entre eux indiquent qu'il serait prêt
ou autres qu'elle considère serait une
bonne chose de faire ou en tout cas
d'appuyer les positions de la part du
président on a répliqué donc sur les
débats par exemple des retraites que sur
les débats sur la fiscalité que chez les
débats sur l'écologie et même que d'une
manière générale sur les politiques
publiques qu'il faut développer qu'on se
retrouve avec une forme d' effet
paradoxal poussée de la gauche dans les
urnes la poussée de la gauche en termes
de nombre de sièges que l'on va pouvoir
constater à l'international et dans un
même élan une politique il sera du fait
d'une condition tactique plus à droite
que ce qu'escompte aujourd'hui une
partie des français il ya quelque chose
qui est pas très clair non plus et le
fameux conseil national de la
refondation qu'a annoncé emmanuel macron
qui pourrait faire concurrence aussi à
part au parlement d'ailleurs c'était
très étrange qu'ils l'annoncent avant
les législatives parce que quelque part
ça pourrait court circuiter l'idée
d'avoir des citoyens tirés au sort
d'avoir des représentants de la société
civile qui puisse discuter des réformes
à venir y compris la réforme des
retraites comment ça s'articule avec le
parlement est ce que ça fait vraiment
concurrence au parlement ce serait une
façon de détourner un petit peu ce qu'il
n'a pas arrêté de faire pendant le
premier quinquennat c'est à dire de pas
trop tenir compte des discussions au
parlement et de les détourner et pas
qu'eux avec le 49-3 mathieu son cas ce
que disait jean daniel lévy est très
important de sable et il en termes d'
équilibre politique dire qu'il ya
d'abord eu un jeu de gaudi politique qui
forcément forcément entretient une forme
de confusion dans le pays l'élection
présidentielle s'est jouée jusqu'au
premier tour à droite et même à droite
toute parce que eric zemmour parce que
marine le pen est parce que les manuels
macron lui-même avait plus le couloir de
centre droit et puis à la faveur du
score de jean luc mélenchon au premier
tour l'entre-deux tours c'est jouer à
gauche ou en tout cas autour de la
notion de planification écologique nous
aurons bien que effectivement emmanuel
macron va être désormais tentés de se
tourner vers la droite en tout état de
cause ce qu'on observe c'est que il y a
une forme de tentations cohabitation
nist dans l'opinion alors que les
français ont dit oui à emmanuel macron à
l'élection présidentielle mais on voit
bien qu'ils n'ont pas envie de dire oui
au maquereau nice ou en tout cas au
maquereau nisme triomphant aux
législatives et que donc emmanuel macron
sera de toute façon tenue de cohabiter
soit avec un représentant de lannux si
c'est ça qui sort des urnes soit en tout
état de cause avec une partie de
l'assemblée venue dlr pour à chaque fois
composer des majorités comme le disait
jean daniel si encore une fois la ligne
directrice c'était la planification
écologique bon courage car la
planification écologique face avec une
majorité porté par les renforcer par les
élèves mais je parlais de la cohésion de
la nu pc assez intéressant parce que
vous vous êtes projeté dans dans la vie
vous avez posé cette question en
français quel avenir pour la nuque 35%
d'entre eux veulent qu'elle continue
cette nouvelle union politique
écologique et sociale d'exister en tant
que tel et 62% ça c'est le chiffre le
plus important 62% des personnes que
vous avez interrogées veulent que les
formations politiques qui constituent la
dube sorte de cette alliance quand vous
analysez s'agit et avec des regards ces
deux là sont intéressantes elles sont
encore plus intéressante quand on
regarde parmi les sympathisants des
quatre formations s'appelait qui forment
la dupe c'est ça est ce qu'ils veulent
la garder ou est-ce qu'il va avancer ça
dépend des cas en fait quand vous
regardez d'une manière générale
notamment les sympathisants socialistes
sont très divisés sur cette question là
et vont dire même à travers deux types
de questions au final satin était plutôt
une alliance tactique pour qu'on puisse
que maintenir un groupe parlementaire et
avoir le plus grande efficacité
électorale mais sur le fond il ya quand
même des points d accord qui
apparaissent comme étant relativement
important ces présents pour la nuque
c'est présent d'ailleurs sur le regard à
l'égard de jean luc mélenchon à vous en
parliez tout à l'heure un regard qui est
un regard assez clivé portées à l'égard
de jean luc mélenchon quand vous
interrogez les français vous avez moins
d'un tiers en fait qu'il souhaite qu'il
devienne demain prémices et que même
parmi les personnes qui se déclarent
proches soit du parti socialiste soit
d'europe écologie les verts ils sont
plutôt d'accord avec des axes
programmatiques que sur la personnalité
de jean-luc mélenchon et donc c'est là
où ça sera intéressant de voir dans
quelle mesure également cette formation
ou en tout cas un conglomérat pourra
résister aux à l'épreuve mais en fait si
je vous entends les uns et les autres ce
second tour est en train de se jouer
comme vous ce que disait mathieu tout à
l'heure c'est un votant contre soit pour
ce vote anti macro on va tenter mais
l'ensemble mais moi j'ai l'impression
qu'un résumer à ça il ya quelques
éléments qui font croire que ça pourrait
perdurer cette nuxe d'abord l'élan qui a
été créé qui a été une quand même une
surprise parce que finalement jean luc
mélenchon si on revient en arrière il ya
un mois on y croyait ce qu'on n'y
croyait cette union elle paraissait
complètement invraisemblable il l'a
réussi en concrétisant les législatives
avec voté pour moi premier ministre il a
réussi une deuxième étape un deuxième
coup de force et en espèces d'élan il
mène des combats ensemble ils sont là
ils ont leur plus belle victoire c'est
celle de dimanche dernier probablement
avoir réussi à tomber à égalité avec
ensemble et puis il ya ce drainage des
jeunes aussi je pense que ça compte
aussi parce qu'en effet c'est l'un des
seuls à parler d'écologie d'une manière
enfin ils sont très très nombreux à ne
pas avoir voté ils sont trés nauséabond
d'abord en upi mais
il ya quand même pas mal de candidats
qui sont jeunes il ya cette idée d'une
autre forme de gauche d'un élan qui est
donné et puis un troisième élément c'est
que dans l'assemblée et s'ils
représentent les là on est à 150 jusqu'à
210 à peu près ça va créer une
opposition on est toujours plus unis
quand on s'oppose à des projets
gouvernementaux ou à des réformes que
qu'on ne souhaite pas c'est à dire qu'on
se serre les coudes pour se dire on va
s'opposer et probablement on se tient
aussi peut-être davantage sur des
positions moins radicale parce que si on
se met en état de gouverner de peser
dans la balance sur les discussions
parlementaires derniers sont là dessus
je souhaite après on parle de la sphère
damien abad mais ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que effectivement le centre
c'est la nouveauté dans notre histoire
politique c'est que le centre de gravité
de la de l'union de la gauche l'union
des gauches est beaucoup plus radicale
du coup plus à l'extrême que ça ne
l'était auparavant ça on l'a bien
expliqué plusieurs fois cette fois ci
mais est ce que ça veut dire que pour
durer cette matière cette coalition elle
doit un peu se recentrer à gauche
présents jeudi en tout cas d'où le
paradoxe il ya une opinion française qui
globalement elle-même au cours des
précédentes années s'est droitisée et
même une partie de la droite 17 extrême
droitiser donc le centre de gravité
politiquement de la société française
s'est déporté vers la droite et on
pourrait avoir peut-être dimanche
prochain une majorité parlementaire de
gauche est effectivement sur une ligne
de gauche non seulement renforcer mais
radicaliser vie met des guillemets donc
effectivement il ya un grand écart qui
est difficile à faire mais sur le fond
tout de même encore une fois les gauches
irréconciliables sur les sujets de fond
ça n'existe pas vraiment il y a des
désaccords politiques mais les enquêtes
d'opinion disent bien que les différents
courants de la gauche se reconnaissent
comme étant d'accord sur l'essentiel est
que les désaccords apparaissent de façon
secondaire et que ceux qui clivent comme
le disait jean daniel ce sont en réalité
les traits d'image de jean luc mélenchon
qui globalement l'opinion est très
rejeter parce qu'il est considéré comme
par les deux tiers ou les trois quarts
des français comme et autoritaire et
démagogique mais même près de 50% des
français qui ont voté pour lui à la
présidentielle sont d'accord pour dire
qu'il est et autoritaire et démagogique
et dernier élément on pointe en réalité
beaucoup comme difficulté incarné par
jean luc mélenchon son rapport à
l'europe en particulier son rapport à la
démocratie et son positionnement sur les
grandes questions internationales
précisément dans une faction de
cohabitation ces sujets là serait pour
partie neutralisée parce que pour partie
ils relèvent du domaine réservé du
président et il ya une différence de
culture fondamentale au delà du respect
réformiste contre radicaux il ya une
gauche qui est plus parlementarisme à
dire dans son fonctionnement interne
qu'à l'habitude de voter des t1 et puis
il ya une gauche saps le ps les écolos
qui votent même sur le vote avant de
faire un vote vraiment une tradition de
notre délibération collective la
détermination de la ligne la
confrontation d'idées la zone le choix
de courant et la gauche de jean luc
mélenchon où on ne veut pas où tout se
décide de par un homme et pour un homme
et un moment quand ils vont devoir se
mettre d'accord ça va ça va clasher
parce qu'il ya quand même une tradition
de gauche où on porte des idées ont des
débats d'idées et puis on tranche aller
le chapitre damien abad la mise et
solidarité de nouveau accusé de
tentative de viol révélations de nos
confrères de mediapart on va en débattre
mais d'abord on écoute la réaction de
marine le pen est la réponse de la
première ministre et isabelle borne
qu'on est en fait il pour considérer
qu'à tout le moins monsieur abad
comportements inappropriés avec les
femmes ce qui semble-t-il était de
notoriété publique dans les milieux qui
le fréquentaient je suis pas juge je ne
suis pas tant des les enquêtes justice
qui les fait et donc je dis à toutes les
femmes qui ont défait à signal pour
qu'elles doivent déposer plainte pour
qu'elles seront bien accueillis
devant dans un commissariat s'ils vont
dans une gendarmerie pour déposer
plainte c'est important que la justice
puisse dire les faits c'est uniquement
la justice qui peut le faire
je rappelle alors c'était évidemment
avancé une nouvelle révélation de
mediapart que les électeurs de la 5e
circonscription de l'ain en place et
damien abad largement en tête au premier
tour 34 % des suffrages il a 12 points
d'avancé sur le candidat de la la nuque
emily's appel ce qui est ce que on se
dit quoi un ministre accusé par de
nouvelles plaignante mais qui sera sans
doute on va on va on va pas pris note du
vote était sans doute conforté par ses
électeurs dimanche m moi j'irai moi je
suis très choqué par ces histoires là
mais depuis depuis même la nomination du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
qui entre temps il ya eu un classement
sans suite comme la plupart du temps moi
je suis très choquée parce que
évidemment qu'il ya la présomption
d'innocence qu'a rappelé emmanuel macron
est évidemment qu'on est pour la
présomption d'innocence mais il ya des
symboles et vous l'avez dit malgré tout
on vote malgré tout on continue
d'avancer j'ai l'impression que sur la
cause des femmes s'il n'y a pas un peu
des symboles si on fait prend pas des
actes un peu fort qu'ils ne vont pas
contre la présomption d'innocence mais
moi je demanderais juste quelque chose
qu'on réfléchisse à sa est ce qu'on
nomme des gens qui sont accusés de viols
ou d'agressions sexuelles simple c'est
même pas une question posée au président
au gouvernement c'est une question de
société si on veut faire avancer les
choses eh bien il faut peut-être qu'on
ait le courage de dire eh ben non
pendant un certain temps peut-être le
curseur ira très très loin mais on peut
pas nommer des gens qui sont agressés et
l'a finalement bon ben voilà la morale
de l'histoire le boulet abad réapparaît
à l'entre-deux tours comme par hasard
voilà ils ont fait le pari que ça serait
beau mais c'était une belle prise des
républicains ça valait le coup même s'il
avait alors il ya une jeune femme qui a
interpellé les abeilles banque qui est
allé une quête aller loin il a dit c'est
plus une casserole qu'il a c'est une
cuisine indienne qui l'a aux fesses mais
oui il ya quelque part cette idée là
emmanuel macron on avait fait sa grande
cause numéro un pour le quinquennat 1 il
en refait sa grande cause numéro 2 ça
veut dire que ça n'avance pas moi je
suis pas une femme féministe acharnée
mais je commence à le devenir parce que
je trouve que ça n'avance pas ces
questions là et que la parole des femmes
ces pauvres femmes qui témoignent
anonyme on comprend bien pourquoi il
faut les aider c'est pas elisabeth bande
a priori qui va le faire puisqu'elle dit
la justice s'occupe de vous vous avez
qu'à aller on vous accompagnons vous
accueille on vous accueille mais après
c'est que là c'est censuré en bas c'est
vrai pour l'instant mais on verra
mathias guerre parce que ça peut être on
attend un peu le premier geste fort des
événements pour marquer son autorité ça
peut être ça obtenir la démission là
vous avez la démission pour mieux se
défendre on connaît tous la formule la
démission damien abad c'est une c'est
une hypothèse je message
portant tout est accroché et on voit
bien que c'est une question complexe que
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord autour
de la façon de traiter par exemple le
cas à bad et c'est un vrai débat
politique c'est un débat de société
intéressant absolument une réalité on
devrait avoir un débat mature et adopter
une position commune ensuite pour
pouvoir traiter de ce genre de sujet
deuxième dimension alors effectivement
la difficulté d'elisabeth bornes c'est
que il ya quelques jours elle avait fait
des déclarations en expliquant que si de
nouveaux éléments seraient portés à sa
connaissance il faudrait agir de
nouveaux éléments manifestement sont
portés à la connaissance de tous donc
va-t-elle du coup agir et la difficulté
c'est que s'ils agissent sur le cadavre
d'un bad il y a effectivement quand même
derrière le cas darmanin qui n'est pas
très différent donc la cohérence
politique elle est de tenir la même
ligne sur hamad est sûre darmanin la
difficulté ce que le parquet a requis un
an
mais on peut dire la même chose pour
pour abad la difficulté dans tous ces
cas en fait c'est la présente sur la
présomption d'innocence tout le monde et
pour la difficulté à invoquer la
présomption d'innocence c'est lorsqu'il
ya une accumulation de cas et c'était le
cas alors et non dans un autre registre
avec un ppda ou avec un nicolas hulot
vous pouvez tout à fait plaider
l'innocence la présomption d'innocence
quand vous avez parole contre parole un
cas qui sort guilde à trois casses cinq
cas où vingt cas ça devient de plus en
plus difficiles comme ligne à tenir dans
le contexte quel nourrir mais je reviens
à la question de l'opinion et notamment
des électeurs de là j'ai eu la curiosité
de chercher le score de damien abad ya
cinq ans pour voir s'ils avaient
beaucoup perdu au premier tour
absolument pas c'est c'est presque le
même jour citer 35 % il ya cinq ans et
ses 34% je sais ça à peu de choses près
la même chose ça veut dire quoi se dire
pardon nous intime que localement les
affaires imprime pas forcément la même
façon que nationalement que ou alors que
c'est parce que ce parce que c'est une
affaire de 2,2 de viol d'agression
sexuelle et que ça l'opinion dans notre
moyen a fait enfin oui c'est assez
difficile à analyser on va pas faire de
politique ou de votre fiction mais
provoquent aussi damien abad n'avait pas
été connue dans sa circonscription que
le regard on était quand même bien plus
sévère et il était connu il été
identifié il était présent ça aurait été
un candidat parachuté en fait s'arrêter
je pense de la sanction d'opinion aurait
été bien plus dur là c'est un peu le
voisin qu'on connaît le député qu'on
connaît qu'on arrive à identifier et
d'autre on se dit je le connais depuis
tellement longtemps que c'est pas
possible et donc en fait à une forme de
mise à distance des accusations qu'il
soit fait et donc qu'ils sont pas
toujours extrêmement prégnante à son
égard ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
enfin on a vu en fait que d'autres
députés avaient rencontré des
difficultés pour des aspects qui par
ailleurs peuvent être apparaître comme
étant nettement moins grave dans les
charentes maritimes si je me trompe pas
monsieur lambert en fait il ya eu des
vraies difficultés alors que c'est un
député sortant et qui n'a pas pu être
présent au deuxième tour ce qui est
probablement deux points de mesure avec
la perception que oui il ya des faits
qui peut être avérée d'une noce cayenne
sont immédiates et de l'autre peut-être
qu'au final ce qu'on lui reproche et
profondément injuste et que la défense
qui a été utilisé par monsieur habana
sauf une en tous cas à l'égard en fait
de ceux qui le connaissent et qu'ils
identifient depuis de nombreuses années
disque a priori ça ressemble plus à de
la calomnie qu'est la réalité juste pour
revenir parce qu'il parle aussi de sa
condition physique ce qu'il est
handicapé donc idi ango moi je peux le
pas le fermer donc on peut comprendre et
ça peut jouer aussi
oui évidemment c'est compliqué pour lui
et vous rendez compte si c'est vrai en
face moi je trouve que la société a
beaucoup de mal et la société souvent
dirigées par des hommes on en est le
reflet là vous ne serez cela a toujours
du mal elles ont déséquilibré
a
du mal à se mettre dans la situation
d'une femme si c'était vrai vous vous
rendez-compte d'aller témoigner en
disant oui malgré son handicap il m'a
attrapée comme ça et comme ça c'est ce
que ce qu'a fait la jeune femme qui
témoigne à nouveau en expliquant un
petit peu comment ça s'est passé donc
c'est ça peut être à double tranchant
son handicap parce que si ça se révèle
s'il ya véritablement une plainte qui
poursuivent y aller je voudrais ouvrir
un tout dernier chapitre avec vous
mathieu concernant eric zemmour parce
qu'on en a pas du tout parlé c'est assez
révélateur depuis depuis dimanche soir
des fêtes d'éric zemmour dès le premier
tour dans le var à saint tropez battu
avec 23 un peu plus de 23% des suffrages
nouvelle défaite et mais oui deux
défaites en deux mois quatrième homme de
la présidentielle avec 7% des voix
cinquième force politique des
législatives avec 4 2% des suffrages et
0 députés tous ses alliés tous ces
ralliés ont mordu la poussière
quel naufrage et quelle histoire quand
même celle d'un homme qui s'est rêvé si
haut pour terminer si l'accord on a un
peu l'impression d'avoir assisté à un
drôle de film une tragique comique ou
dépôt vente c'est selon il ya encore six
mois souvenez-vous eric zemmour occuper
le coeur de l'espace médiatique et
donner le tournis aux instituts de
sondage il fige et une lueur bleue aux
états majors politiques et puis
aujourd'hui nous voilà réduits au rang
de brèves ou d'articles de bas de page
dans les journaux nouvelle victime de la
fameuse règle des 3 l on lèche on lâche
on alors que réserve regard sur notre
métier aussi aux séries tu aussi que lui
restera-t-il d'eric zemmour et d'user
morisseau se poser la question pour
l'homme d'abord est-ce qu'il va demeurer
un imprécateur qui est un domaine où il
excelle ou est ce qu'il va devenir et
achever sa mue
titien bon qu'il déteste au risque de se
banaliser comme un dupont corian par
exemple est ce qu'il reste pour les
siens un espoir de reconquête ou est ce
qu'il est devenu le chat noir de leur
ambition est ce qu'il aura fait au fond
une incursion dans le paysage politique
ou est-ce qu'il a posé un jalon une
fondation c'est toutes les questions
qu'on peut se poser sur lui puis sur les
zemmouris smpt au fond est-ce que c'est
un film littéraire ou est ce que c'est
vraiment la base d'une offre politique
avec des pourcentages de chiffres est-ce
que c'est l'expression d'un malaise
identitaire ou est ce que c'est juste un
nouveau visage la vieille de xénophobie
française et puis son rêve d'union des
droites est ce que c'est un objectif
atteignable un peu à l'image de l'union
des élus de la gauche pour cet accord
électoral ou est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui n'aboutira jamais vous l'aurez
noté je pose beaucoup de questions sans
apporter de réponse parce que je pense
qu'il est trop tôt de cette façon et que
c'est loin d'être évident maintenant on
peut quand même essayer de tirer un
petit bilan en essayant d'abord de
comprendre à quoi il est servi question
de savoir à quoi il pourrait resservir
et au fond grisé mort a été à la fois un
révélateur et un camoufleur révélateur
de la faiblesse de la droite
parlementaire mes yeux une droite
paresseuse et désorientée après cinq ans
de maquereaux nisme qu'on a vu emboîté
le pas du polémiste et de quelle façon
un quasi obsessionnelle notamment
pendant les débats de la primaire heller
alors les plus modérés même les plus
modérés comme michel barnier valérie
pécresse ils auront perdu leur ligne un
peu de leur âme et au final les
élections c'est pour le côté un
révélateur des des fractures de la
droite qui ne ne pouvait pas faire
autrement selon elle que de suivre ses
pas et puis le côté camoufleurs c'est
évidemment le camoufleur de la
radicalité du lepénisme en étant plus
dur plus xénophobes les plus extrêmes
que l'extrême droite
eric zemmour a offert sur un plateau à
marine le pen la dernière étape de sa
dédiabolisation en politique ça porte un
nom on appelle ça un idiot utile mais
idiot eric zemmour ne l'est pas utile en
revanche c'est toute la question allait
il nous reste peu de temps à moi un mot
pour chacun d'entre vous c'était pas
possible d'avoir juste une offre
politique axée sur le grand emplacement
l'immigration la sécurité ça marche pas
je pense que l'utilité maximum c'est
même plus que la dédiabolisation c'est
la normalisation de le pen les
compagnies qu'il a réussi si on compare
son score final 7 % au 17 pour cent
qu'ils avaient quasiment atteint dans
certains sondages c'est une défaite
évidemment mais 7% alité ça fait qu'il
est dans les quatre candidats à
l'élection présidentielle à être
remboursé de ses dépenses de campagne ça
fait qu'avec 7 % il fait plus que
valérie pécresse et anne hidalgo réunis
la candidate du ps la candidate des
républicains ça fait qu'il fait plus que
par exemple un nicolas dupont aignan -
philippe de villiers qui ont été qui ont
incarné sa politiquement au cours des
précédents scrutins donc je pense qu'il
n'est pas mort et j'y ajoute une
dimension c'est grâce quand même à eric
zemmour que l'extrême droite est aussi
haute et au score de duras son ancien
dans le législatif il faudrait en
réalité en toute justice ajouter les 4
et demi pour cent que fait eric zemmour
aux législatives c'est surtout l'extrême
droite qui en réalité se redresse merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat mathieu sookia j'appelle le titre
de votre livre 2022 la flambée populiste
coécrit avec damien fleurot est publié
aux éditions plon